The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer
high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
The topic for today is going to
be equations of planes,
and how they relate to linear
systems and matrices as we have
seen during Tuesday's lecture.
So, let's start again with
equations of planes.
Remember, we've seen briefly
that an equation for a plane is
of the form ax by cz = d,
where a, b, c,
and d are just numbers.
This expresses the condition
for a point at coordinates x,
y, z, to be in the plane.
An equation of this form
defines a plane.
Let's see how that works, again.
Let's start with an example.
Let's say that we want to find
the equation of a plane through
the origin with normal vector --
-- let's say vector N equals the
vector <1,5,
10>.
How do we find an equation of
this plane?
Remember that we can get an
equation by thinking
geometrically.
So, what's our thinking going
to be?
Well, we have the x, y, z axes.
And, we have this vector N:
.
It's supposed to be
perpendicular to our plane.
And, our plane passes through
the origin here.
So, we want to think of the
plane that's perpendicular to
this vector.
Well, when is a point in that
plane?
Let's say we have a point,
P -- -- at coordinates x,
y, z.
Well, the condition for P to be
in the plane should be that we
have a right angle here.
OK, so P is in the plane
whenever OP dot N is 0.
And, if we write that
explicitly, the vector OP has
components x,
y, z;
N has components 1,5, 10.
So that will give us x 5y 10z =
0.
That's the equation of our
plane.
Now, let's think about a
slightly different problem.
So, let's do another problem.
Let's try to find the equation
of the plane through the point
P0 with coordinates,
say, (2,1,-1),
with normal vector,
again, the same N = <1,5,
10>.
How do we find an equation of
this thing?
Well, we're going to use the
same method.
In fact, let's think for a
second.
I said we have our normal
vector, N, and it's going to be
perpendicular to both planes at
the same time.
So, in fact,
our two planes will be parallel
to each other.
The difference is,
well, before,
we had a plane that was
perpendicular to N,
and passing through the origin.
And now, we have a new plane
that's going to pass not through
the origin but through this
point, P0.
I don't really know where it
is, but let's say,
for example,
that P0 is here.
Then, I will just have to shift
my plane so that,
instead of passing through the
origin, it passes through this
new point.
How am I going to do that?
Well, now, for a point P to be
in our new plane,
we need the vector no longer OP
but P0P to be perpendicular to
N.
So P is in this new plane if
the vector P0P is perpendicular
to N.
And now, let's think,
what's the vector P0P?
Well, we take the coordinates
of P, and we subtract those of
P0.
So, that should be x-2,
y-1, and z 1,
dot product with <1,5,
10> equals 0.
Let's expand this.
We get (x-2) 5(y-1) 10(z 1) = 0.
Let's put the constants on the
other side.
We get: x 5y 10z equals -- here
minus two becomes two,
minus five becomes five,
ten becomes minus ten.
I think we end up with negative
three.
So, the only thing that changes
between these two equations is
the constant term on the
right-hand side,
the thing that I called d.
The other common feature is
that the coefficients of x,
y, and z: one,
five, and ten,
correspond exactly to the
normal vector.
That's something you should
remember about planes.
These coefficients here
correspond exactly to a normal
vector and, well,
this constant term here roughly
measures how far you move
from...
I f you have a plane through
the origin, the right-hand side
will be zero.
And, if you move to a parallel
plane, then this number will
become something else.
Actually, how could we have
found that -3 more quickly?
Well, we know that the first
part of the equation is like
this.
And we know something else.
We know that the point P0 is in
the plane.
So, if we plug the coordinates
of P0 into this,
well, x is 2 5 times 1 10 times
-1.
We get -3.
So, in fact,
the number we should have here
should be minus three so that P0
is a solution.
Let me point out -- (I'll put a
1 here again) -- these three
numbers: 1,5,
10, are exactly the normal
vector.
And one way that we can get
this number here is by computing
the value of the left-hand side
at the point P0.
We plug in the point P0 into
the left hand side.
OK, any questions about that?
By the way, of course,
a plane doesn't have just one
equation.
It has infinitely many
equations because if instead,
say, I multiply everything by
two, 2x 10y 20z = -6 is also an
equation for this plane.
That's because we have normal
vectors of all sizes -- we can
choose how big we make it.
Again, the single most
important thing here:
in the equation ax by cz = d,
the coefficients,
a, b, c, give us a normal
vector to the plane.
So, that's why,
in fact, what matters to us the
most is finding the normal
vector.
In particular,
if you remember,
last time I explained something
about how we can find a normal
vector to a plane if we know
points in the plane.
Namely, we can take the cross
product of two vectors contained
in the plane.
Let's just do an example to see
if we completely understand
what's going on.
Let's say that I give you the
vector with components
,
and I give you the plane x y 3z
= 5.
So, do you think that this
vector is parallel to the plane,
perpendicular to it,
neither?
I'm starting to see a few votes.
OK, I see that most of you are
answering number two:
this vector is perpendicular to
the plane.
There are some other answers
too.
Well, let's try to figure it
out.
Let's do the example.
Say v is <1,2,
-1> and the plane is x y 3z
= 5.
Let's just draw that plane
anywhere -- it doesn't really
matter.
Let's first get a normal vector
out of it.
Well, to get a normal vector to
the plane, what I will do is
take the coefficients of x,
y, and z.
So, that's .
So
is perpendicular to the plane.
How do we get all the other
vectors that are perpendicular
to the plane?
Well, all the perpendicular
vectors are parallel to each
other.
That means that they are just
obtained by multiplying this guy
by some number.
for example,
would still be perpendicular to
the plane.
is also perpendicular to the
plane.
But now, see,
these guys are not proportional
to each other.
So, V is not perpendicular to
the plane.
So it's not perpendicular to
Being perpendicular to the
plane is the same as being
parallel to its normal vector.
Now, what about testing if v
is, instead, parallel to the
plane?
Well, it's parallel to the
plane if it's perpendicular to
N.
Let's check.
So, let's try to see if v is
perpendicular to N.
Well, let's do v.N.
That's <1,2,
- 1> dot <1,1,
3>.
You get 1 2 - 3=0.
So, yes.
If it's perpendicular to N,
it means -- It's actually going
to be parallel to the plane.
OK, any questions?
Yes?
[QUESTION FROM STUDENT:]
When you plug the vector into
the plane equation,
you get zero.
What does that mean?
Let's see.
If I plug the vector into the
plane equation:
1 2-3, well,
the left hand side becomes
zero.
So, it's not a solution of the
plane equation.
There's two different things
here.
One is that the point with
coordinates (1,2,- 1) is not in
the plane.
What that tells us is that,
if I put my vector V at the
origin, then its head is not
going to be in the plane.
On the other hand,
you're right,
the left hand side evaluates to
zero.
What that means is that,
if instead I had taken the
plane x y 3z = 0,
then it would be inside.
The plane is x y 3z = 5,
so x y 3z = 0 would be a plane
parallel to it,
but through the origin.
So, that would be another way
to see that the vector is
parallel to the plane.
If we move the plane to a
parallel plane through the
origin, then the endpoint of the
vector is in the plane.
OK, that's another way to
convince ourselves.
Any other questions?
OK, let's move on.
So, last time we learned about
matrices and linear systems.
So, let's try to think,
now, about linear systems in
terms of equations of planes and
intersections of planes.
Remember that a linear system
is a bunch of equations -- say,
a 3x3 linear system is three
different equations.
Each of them is the equation of
a plane.
So, in fact,
if we try to solve a system of
equations, that means actually
we are trying to find a point
that is on several planes at the
same time.
So...
Let's say that we have a 3x3
linear system.
Just to take an example -- it
doesn't really matter what I
give you, but let's say I give
you x z = 1, x y = 2,
x 2y 3z = 3.
What does it mean to solve this?
It means we want to find x,
y, z which satisfy all of these
conditions.
Let's just look at the first
equation, first.
Well, the first equation says
our point should be on the plane
which has this equation.
Then, the second equation says
that our point should also be on
that plane.
So, if you just look at the
first two equations,
you have two planes.
And the solutions -- these two
equations determine for you two
planes, and two planes intersect
in a line.
Now, what happens with the
third equation?
That's actually going to be a
third plane.
So, if we want to solve the
first two equations,
we have to be on this line.
And if we want to solve the
third one, we also need to be on
another plane.
And, in general,
the three planes intersect in a
point because this line of
intersection...
Three planes intersect in a
point,
and one way to think about it
is that the line where the first
two planes intersect meets the
third plane in a point.
And, that point is the solution
to the linear system.
The line -- this is
mathematical notation for the
intersection between the first
two planes -- intersects the
third plane in a point,
which is going to be the
solution.
So, how do we find the solution?
One way is to draw pictures and
try to figure out where the
solution is, but that's not how
we do it in practice if we are
given the equations.
Let me use matrix notation.
Remember, we saw on Tuesday
that the solution to AX = B is
given by X = A inverse B.
We got from here to there by
multiplying on the left by A
inverse.
A inverse AX simplifies to X
equals A inverse B.
And, once again,
it's A inverse B and not BA
inverse.
If you try to set up the
multiplication,
BA inverse doesn't work.
The sizes are not compatible,
you can't multiply the other
way around.
OK, that's pretty good --
unless it doesn't work that way.
What could go wrong?
Well, let's say that our first
two planes do intersect nicely
in a line, but let's think about
the third plane.
Maybe the third plane does not
intersect that line nicely in a
point.
Maybe it's actually parallel to
that line.
Let's try to think about this
question for a second.
Let's say that the set of
solutions to a 3x3 linear system
is not just one point.
So, we don't have a unique
solution that we can get this
way.
What do you think could happen?
OK, I see that answers number
three and five seem to be
dominating.
There's also a bit of answer
number one.
In fact, these are pretty good
answers.
I see that some of you figured
out that you can answer one and
three at the same time,
or three and five at the same
time.
I yet have to see somebody with
three hands answer all three
numbers at the same time.
OK.
Indeed, we'll see very soon
that we could have either no
solution, a line,
or a plane.
The other answers:
"two points"
(two solutions),
we will see,
is actually not a possibility
because if you have two
different solutions,
then the entire line through
these two points is also going
to be made of solutions.
"A tetrahedron"
is just there to amuse you,
it's actually not a good answer
to the question.
It's not very likely that you
will get a tetrahedron out of
intersecting planes.
"A plane"
is indeed possible,
and "I don't know"
is still OK for a few more
minutes,
but we're going to get to the
bottom of this,
and then we will know.
OK, let's try to figure out
what can happen.
Let me go back to my picture.
I had my first two planes;
they determine a line.
And now I have my third plane.
Maybe my third plane is
actually parallel to the line
but doesn't pass through it.
Well, then, there's no
solutions because,
to solve the system of
equations, I need to be in the
first two planes.
So, that means I need to be in
that vertical line.
(That line was supposed to be
red, but I guess it doesn't
really show up as red).
And it also needs to be in the
third plane.
But the line and the plane are
parallel to each other.
There's just no place where
they intersect.
So there's no way to solve all
the equations.
On the other hand,
the other thing that could
happen is that actually the line
is contained in the plane.
And then, any point on that
line will automatically solve
the third equation.
So if you try solving a system
that looks like this by hand,
if you do substitutions,
eliminations,
and so on,
what you will notice is that,
after you have dealt with two
of the equations,
the third one would actually
turn out to be the same as what
you got out of the first two.
It doesn't give you any
additional information.
It's as if you had only two
equations.
The previous case would be when
actually the third equation
contradicts something that you
can get out of the first two.
For example,
maybe out of the first two,
you got that x plus z equals
one, and the third equation is x
plus z equals two.
Well, it can't be one and two
at the same time.
Another way to say it is that
this picture is one where you
can get out of the equations
that a number equals a different
number.
That's impossible.
And, that picture is one where
out of the equations you get
zero equals zero,
which is certainly true,
but isn't a very useful
equation.
So, you can't actually finish
solving.
OK, let me write that down.
unless the third plane is
parallel to the line where P1
and P2 intersect.
Then there's two subcases.
If the line of intersections of
P1 and P2 is actually contained
in P3 (the third plane),
then we have infinitely many
solutions.
Namely, any point on the line
will automatically solve the
third equation.
The other subcase is if the
line of the intersection of P1
and P2 is parallel to P3 and not
contained in it.
Then we get no solutions.
Just to show you the pictures
once again: when we have the
first two planes,
they give us a line.
And now, depending on what
happens to that line in relation
to the third plane,
various situations can happen.
If the line hits the third
plane in a point,
then that's going to be our
solution.
If that line,
instead, is parallel to the
third plane, well,
if it's parallel and outside of
it, then we have no solution.
If it's parallel and contained
in it, then we have infinitely
many solutions.
So, going back to our list of
possibilities,
let's see what can happen.
No solution:
we've seen that it happens when
the line where the first two
planes intersect is parallel to
the third one.
Two points: well,
that didn't come up.
As I said, the problem is that,
if the line of intersections of
the first two planes has two
points that are in the third
plane,
then that means the entire line
must actually be in the third
plane.
So, if you have two solutions,
then you have more than two.
In fact, you have infinitely
many, and we've seen that can
happen.
A tetrahedron:
still doesn't look very
promising.
What about a plane?
Well, that's a case that I
didn't explain because I've been
assuming that P1 and P2 are
different planes and they
intersect in a line.
But, in fact,
they could be parallel,
in which case we already have
no solution to the first two
equations;
or they could be the same plane.
And now, if the third plane is
also the same plane -- if all
three planes are the same plane,
then you have a plane of
solutions.
If I give you three times the
same equation,
that is a linear system.
It's not a very interesting
one, but it's a linear system.
And "I don't know"
is no longer a solution either.
OK, any questions?
[STUDENT QUESTION:]
What's the geometric
significance of the plane x y z
equals 1, as opposed to 2,
or 3?
That's a very good question.
The question is,
what is the geometric
significance of an equation like
x y z equals to 1,2,
3, or something else?
Well, if the equation is x y z
equals zero, it means that our
plane is passing through the
origin.
And then, if we change the
constant, it means we move to a
parallel plane.
So, the first guess that you
might have is that this number
on the right-hand side is the
distance between the origin and
the plane.
It tells us how far from the
origin we are.
That is not quite true.
In fact, that would be true if
the coefficients here formed a
unit vector.
Then this would just be the
distance to the origin.
Otherwise, you have to actually
scale by the length of this
normal vector.
And, I think there's a problem
in the Notes that will show you
exactly how this works.
You should think of it roughly
as how much we have moved the
plane away from the origin.
That's the meaning of the last
term, D, in the right-hand side
of the equation.
So, let's try to think about
what exactly these cases are --
how do we detect in which
situation we are?
It's all very nice in the
picture, but it's difficult to
draw planes.
In fact, when I draw these
pictures, I'm always very
careful not to actually pretend
to draw an actual plane given by
an equation.
When I do, then it's blatantly
false -- it's difficult to draw
a plane correctly.
So, instead,
let's try to think about it in
terms of matrices.
In particular,
what's wrong with this?
Why can't we always say the
solution is X = A inverse B?
Well, the point is that,
actually, you cannot always
invert a matrix.
Recall we've seen this formula:
A inverse is one over
determinant of A times the
adjoint matrix.
And we've learned how to
compute this thing:
remember, we had to take
minors, then flip some signs,
and then transpose.
That step we can always do.
We can always do these
calculations.
But then, at the end,
we have to divide by the
determinant.
That's fine if the determinant
is not zero.
But, if the determinant is
zero, then certainly we cannot
do that.
What I didn't mention last time
is that the matrix is invertible
-- that means it has an inverse
-- exactly when its determinant
is not zero.
That's something we should
remember.
So, if the determinant is not
zero, then we can use our method
to find the inverse.
And then we can solve using
this method.
If not, then not.
Yes?
[STUDENT QUESTION:]
Sorry, can you reexplain that?
You can invert A if the
determinant of A is not equal to
zero?
That's correct.
We can invert the matrix A if
the determinant is not zero.
If you look again at the method
that we saw last time:
first we had to compute the
adjoint matrix.
And, these are operations we
can always do.
If we are given a 3x3 matrix,
we can always compute the
adjoint.
And then, the last step to find
the inverse was to divide by the
determinant.
And that we can only do if the
determinant is not zero.
So, if we have a matrix whose
determinant is not zero,
then we know how to find the
inverse.
If the determinant is zero,
then of course this method
doesn't work.
I'm actually saying even more:
there isn't an inverse at all.
It's not just that our method
fails.
I cannot take the inverse of a
matrix with determinant zero.
Geometrically,
the situation where the
determinant is not zero is
exactly this nice usual
situation where the three planes
intersect in a point,
while the situation where the
determinant is zero is this
situation here where the line
determined by the first two
planes is parallel to the third
plane.
Let me emphasize this again,
and let's see again what
happens.
Let's start with an easier case.
It's called the case of a
homogeneous system.
It's called homogeneous because
it's the situation where the
equations are invariant under
scaling.
So, a homogeneous system is one
where the right hand side is
zero -- there's no B.
If you want,
the constant terms here are all
zero: 0,0, 0.
OK, so this one is not
homogenous.
So, let's see what happens
there.
Let's take an example.
Instead of this system,
we could take x z = 0,
x y = 0, and x 2y 3z also
equals zero.
Can we solve these equations?
I think actually you already
know a very simple solution to
these equations.
Yeah, you can just take x,
y, and z all to be zero.
So, there's always an obvious
solution -- -- namely,
(0,0, 0).
And, in mathematical jargon,
this is called the trivial
solution.
There's always this trivial
What's the geometric
interpretation?
Well, having zeros here means
that all three planes pass
through the origin.
So, certainly the origin is
always a solution.
The origin is always a solution
because the three planes -- --
pass through the origin.
Now there's two subcases.
One case is if the determinant
of the matrix A is nonzero.
That means that we can invert A.
So, if we can invert A,
then we can solve the system by
multiplying by A inverse.
If we multiply by A inverse,
we'll get X equals A inverse
times zero, which is zero.
That's the only solution
because,
if AX is zero,
then let's multiply by A
inverse: we get that A inverse
AX, which is X,
equals A inverse zero,
which is zero.
We get that X equals zero.
We've solved it,
there's no other solution.
To go back to these pictures
that we all enjoy,
it's this case.
Now the other case,
if the determinant of A equals
zero, then this method doesn't
quite work.
What does it mean that the
determinant of A is zero?
Remember, the entries in A are
the coefficients in the
equations.
But now, the coefficients in
the equations are exactly the
normal vectors to the planes.
So, that's the same thing as
saying that the determinant of
the three normal vectors to our
three planes is 0.
That means that N1,
N2, and N3 are actually in a
same plane -- they're coplanar.
These three vectors are
coplanar.
So, let's see what happens.
I claim it will correspond to
this situation here.
Let's draw the normal vectors
to these three planes.
(Well, it's not very easy to
see, but I've tried to draw the
normal vectors to my planes.)
They are all in the direction
that's perpendicular to the line
of intersection.
They are all in the same plane.
So, if I try to form a
parallelepiped with these three
normal vectors,
well, I will get something
that's completely flat,
and has no volume,
has volume zero.
So the parallelepiped -- -- has
volume 0.
And the fact that the normal
vectors are coplanar tells us
that, in fact -- (well,
let me start a new blackboard).
Let's say that our normal
vectors, N1, N2,
N3, are all in the same plane.
And let's think about the
direction that's perpendicular
to N1, N2, and N3 at the same
time.
I claim that it will be the
line of intersection.
So, let me try to draw that
picture again.
We have three planes -- (now
you see why I prepared a picture
in advance.
It's easier to draw it
beforehand).
And I said their normal vectors
are all in the same plane.
What else do I know?
I know that all these planes
pass through the origin.
So the origin is somewhere in
the intersection of the three
planes.
Now, I said that the normal
vectors to my three planes are
all actually coplanar.
So N1, N2, N3 determine a plane.
Now, if I look at the line
through the origin that's
perpendicular to N1,
N2, and N3,
so, perpendicular to this red
plane here,
it's supposed to be in all the
planes.
(You can see that better on the
side screens).
And why is that?
Well, that's because my line is
perpendicular to the normal
vectors, so it's parallel to the
planes.
It's parallel to all the planes.
Now, why is it in the planes
instead of parallel to them?
Well, that's because my line
goes through the origin,
and the origin is on the
planes.
So, certainly my line has to be
contained in the planes,
not parallel to them.
So the line through the origin
and perpendicular to the plane
of N1, N2, N3 -- -- is parallel
to all three planes.
And, because the planes go
through the origin,
it's contained in them.
So what happens here is I have,
in fact, infinitely many
solutions.
How do I find these solutions?
Well, if I want to find
something that's perpendicular
to N1, N2, and N3 -- if I just
want to be perpendicular to N1
and N2,
I can take their cross product.
So, for example,
N1 cross N2 is perpendicular to
N1 and to N2,
and also to N3,
because N3 is in the same plane
as N1 and N2,
so, if you're perpendicular to
N1 and N2, you are also
perpendicular to N3.
It's automatic.
So, it's a nontrivial solution.
This vector goes along the line
of intersections.
OK, that's the case of
homogeneous systems.
And then, let's finish with the
other case, the general case.
If we look at a system,
AX = B, with B now anything,
there's two cases.
If the determinant of A is not
zero, then there is a unique
solution -- -- namely,
X equals A inverse B.
If the determinant of A is
zero,
then it means we have the
situation with planes that are
all parallel to a same line,
and then we have either no
solution or infinitely many
solutions.
It cannot be a single solution.
Now, whether you have no
solutions or infinitely many
solutions, we haven't actually
developed the tools to answer
that.
But, if you try solving the
system by hand,
by elimination,
you will see that you end up
maybe with something that says
zero equals zero,
and you have infinitely many
solutions.
Actually, if you can find one
solution, then you know that
there's infinitely many.
On the other hand,
if you end up with something
that's a contradiction,
like one equals two,
then you know there's no
solutions.
That's the end for today.
Tomorrow, we will learn about
parametric equations for lines
and curves.